[Musica]
ad ogni luna piena tornerà il lupo
mannaro non è fantastico
se vuoi rompere la maledizione dovrai
superare tutte le prove a e poi
ovviamente ci sarà la prova finale ma
ora è meglio che inizi il viaggio perché
il tempo sta passando e la prossima luna
piena si avvicina segui la mappa e
ricordate non verrai lupo mannaro per
sempre rimarrà quante saranno le tappe
soprattutto dove dobbiamo andare prima
al castello forse o poi avete sentito
qualcosa
[Musica]
ciao a tutti le reti dei data i soci
nuovo giorno bellissima giornata
guardate come fuori che bello bari le
barche a vela c'è tantissimo sole però
purtroppo non abbiamo ancora trovato la
nuova lettera quindi non possiamo
continuare la challenge
[Musica]
ieri non ho controllato quali non
abbiamo guardato 4
cos'è quello
vi ricordate che si è uno dei mostri del
parco dei mostri giusti era l'orco del
parco dei mostri
[Musica]
la lettera era quasi tutto il tempo
presso leggiamo la vediamo cos'altro si
aspetta questo che cosa vorrà dire però
che non sia un talismano che ci porta
sfortuna
secondo voi dovremo tenerlo dovrei
lasciarlo qui da qualche parte
scrivete nei commenti vediamo qual è la
nostra prossima challenge dice c'è
scritto benvenuti siete quasi giunti
alla fine del viaggio una delle vostre
ultime prove fra di vedere dei lupi veri
attenti a non farli arrabbiare sono
affamati firmato il re ora ho capito
perché nella mappa ci sono dei simboli
dei lupi dobbiamo andare a vedere i lupi
veri ma sono emozionatissimo perché ho
sempre voluto vedere dei lupi veri però
dice che sono affamati
cerchiamo di stare attenti ok e questo
corto lo lascio qua non si sa mai che mi
porti sfortuna
andiamo subito a vedere i lupi veri e
voi verrete con noi ma lasciate un mi
piace qua sotto mi raccomando pronti
vixi qua ci troviamo nell'area
faunistica del lupo a pretoro dove viene
appunto salvaguardata la specie
noi ci siamo emozionati tantissimo nel
vedere dei veri ruby dal vivo ovviamente
dovevamo fare il silenzio per non
disturbarli ed eravamo in una struttura
lontana ipotesi non spaventarli come
potete vedere sono
bellissimi appunto noi ci siamo
emozionati tantissimo nel frattempo che
le osservate video qualche informazione
su questo bellissimo animale
infatti il lupo un tempo era uno dei
mammiferi più diffusi al mondo
soprattutto nell'emisfero boreale
poi però purtroppo è iniziata la
persecuzione da parte dell'uomo e che ha
provocato poi la sua estinzione in gran
parte dell'europa occidentale del
messico e degli stati uniti d'america
infatti ogni anno in italia sono circa
300 i lupi che muoiono a causa dell'uomo
e di questi almeno uno su due è vittima
di bracconaggio
il lupo comunque un animale sociale
infatti la sua forza resistenza e
adattabilità nasce proprio dall
esistenza del branco infatti i lupi
vivono in branco che come una famiglia
infatti è costituita da una coppia di
genitori poi ci sono i piccoli quindi
cuccioli che sono nati in quell'anno
e poi ci sono i lupi giovani infatti il
branco fornisce a tutti i membri del
gruppo protezione risorse e opportunità
di crescita nel branco c'è sempre il
capo branco che il maschio alfa che poi
seguito dalla sua compagna con la
compagna formano una coppia monogama
quindi stanno insieme per tutta la vita
le dimensioni dei lupi cambiano in base
a dove si trovano quindi alla località
geografica ci sono le popolazioni
meridionali che sono più piccole di
quelle nordiche
comunque in generale la lunghezza del
corpo e di 100 130 centimetri nei maschi
e 87 117 centimetri nelle femmine
la quota è lunga dai 35 52 cm
[Musica]
penso e per il peso besano una media di
55 45 kg quella che vedete qua e la
femmina vedete che il colore leggermente
diverso era bellissima e qua sta facendo
la bp marcando il territorio anche il
colore della pelliccia dei lupi infatti
varia può essere addirittura al bianco
candido nelle popolazioni artiche invece
in quelle del nord america c'è
addirittura il lupo nero questo che
state vedendo che avete visto questi tre
lupi sono dei lupi appenninici sono
veramente stupendi noi ci siamo
emozionati tantissimo nel vederli dal
vivo nel vedere queste aree faunistiche
che si occupano di reintrodurre la
specie di salvaguardarla fatemi sapere
nei commenti se vi piacciono i lupi
lasciato un bel mi piace a questo video
che conoscevate in queste informazioni
sui lupi o se volete iscrivermi anche
voi qualche informazione sui lupi nei
commenti e vi saluto e vi mando un
abbraccio al prossimo episodio
[Musica]